hi sorry i'm just doing a quick audio
check here
are you able to hear me now
i can great
thank you paris i think uh learners were
not able to hear you
okay let's uh now it's good uh please
can you confirm if you're able to hear
paris now yes
can you hear me great i do see
confirmation thank you over to you paris
good evening good morning everyone here
uh welcome to the purdue
simply earn second pgp batch of 21
convocation
i am paris working as senior program
manager with simply learn
in learner success group i take care of
learners experience
in digital business and digital
operations
programs i have seven years of
experience in strategy and operations
across startups education space
and cooperates just two years back folks
i
graduated from university of oxford and
i remember how exciting and
fun the convocation was and that's where
i got my
display picture for my social media
accounts
i'm so excited to be here today today is
all about
you know appreciating and celebrating
your success
uh thinking of the journey that all of
you been through
i know it i know it requires a lot of
consistent effort on a day-to-day basis
and a lot of prioritization of learning
over other things
so i'm sure these are the two areas you
have excelled in which is prioritization
of learning over other areas and
consistent efforts it takes a lot of
grit
to finish you know programs like this
hundreds of hours of learning
20 plus assessments and projects uh
kudos to all of you guys this is an
amazing
accomplishment we're all champions i'm
so glad to be here
and i'm super excited uh
to share this moment with all of you
uh we have many senior folks from simply
learn and purdue here
and now i would like to introduce anand
our chief product officer he's a very
pragmatic and
calm product leader very passionate
about
great customer outcomes and customer
centric data data-driven decisions
and he believes in a rapid iterative
lean approach
to deliver to delivering products
he has done his master's in computer
science from texas
a m university and he's done his
undergrad from
nit in computer science and he's also
done his mba
from ut austin mccomb school of business
uh over to you anand i would request you
to share a few words
with our learners on what they have
achieved
so thanks paris hopefully everybody can
hear me i'll just check my check
all right wonderful so the first thing i
wanted to share is
really amazing achievement getting to
this point after
i what is it six nine 12 months in some
cases
to get to this finish line is an
absolutely amazing achievement
and i do recognize this because my team
architects this
program and i know we make this we don't
make this easy do we uh we make it
pretty hard for someone to actually
graduate out of this program so
the first thing is if you've gotten this
far it's a pretty massive achievement it
also means that
you have really worked hard you've done
your capstones you've done your projects
you've actually
submitted them you've got results for
that so pretty amazing
first of all big you know roundup
applause to everybody from my side well
done
uh great work and you know in any
journey what i find
is the journey is part of the success as
well right i
i do believe that you've come to a point
where at this point of time
you know the career is in front of you
you're you know whatever you start to
get out of this program
in front of you but you know the hard
work that you've gone through the kind
of focus that you put in there those
are soft qualities that you will
continue to con you know have as you
progress
out of this program and for that i think
you know you'll realize the value of
that in a few months a few quarters few
years potentially
but more importantly you're walking out
with a few
things one is of course the simple you
know how to do data science data
analytics whether that's digital
marketing
you've got the skills for that now right
but more importantly you're also
graduating with a set of i think there
are 104 folks here that are graduating
with you and
probably more graduating uh attendees
104
keep in mind that you're part of a
select group of people who have actually
mastered this course have come out with
flying colors and have succeeded here
and i encourage you to stay in touch
with each other be part of the community
you know
connect with your fellow learners
because these are the same learners who
are going to succeed alongside you
and i hope you will help each other as
you go forward out of this program
right the last thing is we would love to
hear from you
you know in two or three months when you
finish this program you apply this
knowledge at your work
if you feel like you've got you know
achieved great success out of it
we love to hear about those kind of
stories so do send them to us we would
love to hear about your successes
and you know celebrate with you so
please don't be shy please share that
with us
but at this moment let's just celebrate
the fact that you went through a
grueling
you know many month journey to get to
this point
achieve this outcome and come to the
very finish line
and you're here you know to finally get
the certificate and the result that
you've been looking for
so congratulations to everybody here and
i wish you all the very very best
and uh you know let's make this function
a great success and let's make sure that
you have
great success coming out with this world
back to you paris thank you
thank you for your kind words uh anand
up next we have our guest of honor
today dr matai he's working in super
interesting research areas
including data storytelling trust and
digital knowledge creation
and he also published a book on
wikipedia he has co-authored several
papers and books with his students his
graduate students
they work in the area of computational
methods and social scientific approaches
to human ai
and in terms of teaching his primary
interests
include human ai interaction digital
analytics application
communication technology ai and data
ethics
uh dr matai it's a real pleasure to have
you here
i now i now request you to share a few
words with our grads
uh hello everybody uh thank you uh
to the simply learn team for
honoring me with this invitation uh
heartfelt congratulations to your
students to you the students for
completing this journey
um the one thing that i would like to
share with you uh is my enthusiasm
for your resilience and for your uh
and my congratulations for your choice
um
going through an online program requires
uh stamina resilience
and purpose uh and you all demonstrated
this
uh uh to a
excellent uh degree um more important i
would like to say that
uh online education is is the future
and your choice is the choice of the the
future
i myself as an academic
have been working for quite some time to
bring our operation online because i
think that
our students and the world of tomorrow
demand it in this respect uh
having uh chosen to be trained
through a program i simply learned is a
visionary choice
truly and you should feel very very
proud of it
as i said before i'm truly honored by
the invitation
extended by simply learn and i would
like to congratulate
adam for bringing you
so far and i would like to wish them all
the
luck and uh all the yeah
you know all the good things that could
happen to a company
the young company like like like theirs
in the future
thank you all and congratulations again
thank you dr madai for sharing your rich
insights with our
achievers uh folks now let's
let's look back and let's reflect on our
experience
i assumed the journey would have been
super difficult but let's hear it from
you
on a scale of one to five how difficult
do you think your journey was
let's do a poll and see what what you
guys have to share
we have 30 seconds
i'm looking forward to see the results
five
four three two
one let's look at the results
wow only one percent think it's fairly
difficult
oh that's i see majority lies in three
to four
which i think that's how it should be
you know when your skill
so this is your skill level and this is
the task level
when the task level is above your skill
level you push yourself
but if the task level is too high so
learners become anxious and if the task
level is too low
it gets very boring and you don't learn
and push yourself i think all of you
have
pushed yourself and proven uh yourself
in this area so congratulations once
again
uh folks well done
now let's let's listen first hand from
some of your peers
uh i would i would like to call
some of your peers to to share their
experiences uh
let's start with priyanka
good morning good evening wherever you
are um
hope you're all doing good today
priyanka can you switch on your video
yeah sure
able to see me now yeah
pete so uh i'm priyanka
and i'm very excited to uh share my
journey with you all
so basically i am from a background of
engineering in the field of electronics
and communications
so i've been currently working as a
software developer since seven years
so my basic day-to-day job was dealing
with data
and i always had this passion to take up
something challenging
okay we do data we process data so what
next
so that made me take up or motivated me
to look for a program of
this kind and i'm happy that i made
this decision to take this program
especially i would like to mention that
i like the way the program was designed
because uh
i really did not have any idea uh
related to data science it was
completely new to me
even though i did some kind of research
but uh
the way the pose was designed made it
easier to understand so what to expect
uh what may uh what kind of areas we are
going to explore
so and along with that the hands-on
obviously
no matter how theoretical knowledge
you have or you're good at explaining
things but you also able to
show them uh i mean that's where the
hands-on
part came became really helpful so yeah
and now i am i've completed yes
kudos to myself uh i i made this far and
i i'm happy i'm
looking forward to exploring roles in
this regard and to see myself as a
machine learning engineer soon
thank you thank you simply learn and
point you thanks priyanka very very
interesting
let's have eljin
my ultimate is not on
can can we have engine next
okay let's have santosh or kumati
all right let's let's continue uh
guys next listing to her story how many
of you
think you resonate with with her story
let's let's do another poll to see how
many of you relate
with whether with priyanka's experience
let's start another poll
we have 10 seconds left three
two one let's look at the results
oh wow 74 that's that's very relatable
that's great
guys if you think you have unique
stories which which
which are not related to priyanka's
story feel free to share with us
through the chat window we would love to
hear hear your unique stories
as well
now let's get back to the agenda i would
like to congratulate each one of you
here i would like to announce all the
achievers
here let's let's start the
announcement
all right our achievers for aiml program
uh congratulations jeffrey uh welding
congrats
well we have more in aiml that's that's
great
congratulations michael congrats
congratulations gopi shetty ravi
narasimha congratulations
we're all there's so many achievers with
us today i'm so happy uh
vishwa mohan nikhil
sunni sarathi
let's well we have
now data science achievers uh
congratulations congrats
congratulations congratulations
congratulations
uh we have now data science achievers uh
let's see who are there
uh congrats congrats ramki
congratulations sashi bhushan weldon
well more folks from data science uh
congratulations
suraj congrats neeraj weldon bharpur
congrats sumita congratulations priyanka
congrats keith arun ah congratulations
sharwani congrats rahul
narendra moon
great work surah narayana
well we have more in data science it's a
huge list
congratulations kishore congratulations
congratulations abrata congratulations
shiva
manish sankar
congratulations rajesh weldon basu
weldon priyanka weldon
foreign let's move to the data analyst
nets
we have aniket congratulations uh
weldon stephanie uh good work
rakesh congratulations nisha
congratulations nazia congratulations
mahima
congratulations avilash sharanjeet
weldon with anthony
congrats christina
ranjita congratulations sisha
congratulations john
congratulations vijay lakshmi ishani
congratulations
amazing work folks congratulations
congratulations giant
congratulations praveen great work
tariqa weldon bishop
congratulations nisha congratulations
alyssa
congratulations yogesh congratulations
vipin
congratulations mushashri
congratulations brenton congratulations
vineesh
weldon folks
saba congrats madhuri
tinakar congratulations kelsey
kumaragiri congrats
congratulations ricardo samia well done
weldon ahmadchin great work mohammed
great work vandana congratulations
nicholas
well then look weldon
brahma murad weldon joe
great work sridhi great work arul
great job congratulations mohammed
congratulations harika congratulations
dr ranil
uh congratulations congratulations
retika
weldon babani
congratulations congratulations adewale
congratulations john uh
weldon anub and visune
oh great we have data engineering
achievers
weldon santosh great work
andrei amazing work christopher
congratulations harita congratulations
william
all of you are grads now congratulations
business analysis folks uh
congratulations ramya
weldon mohammed weldon stefan
great work sumrat congratulations
santosh
congratulations sweta congratulations
nabanita congratulations uh
saleh
great uh we have more in business
analysis congratulations shikha
congratulations shree bhagavati
congratulations
mahanteshwar congratulations rachel
great work prasaddy well done
congratulations vanessa congratulations
asha congratulations radhika
congratulations mansi katarjna
congratulations nitin uh great work
ms janet congratulations sandhya
[Music]
congratulations anshul uh great work
paul
congratulations anapuna congratulations
mohammed
congratulations deema weldon
welded great work harika
congratulations bhina weldon
gayatri great job adi
uh congratulations nikhil
congratulations mayank
congratulations revati congratulations
nikkil
ah congratulations cola weldon shruti
welding sharon congratulations
venkatesh congratulations uh suzy
great to see you paul here again
congratulations once again
uh congratulations eddie bogaya
congratulations aishwarya
congratulations michael
valden srilika
okay now we comes now we come to
superstars
among achievers so even amongst
achievers guys we have
folks who have performed extraordinarily
well
and we have two kinds of awards for our
super achievers uh we'll start with
scholars award which is top two
performers
from the cohort in assessments and
projects assessments and projects you
know if you think about
it that's the backbone of our courses
if you do well here you're going to do
great in life
so well done to all these extraordinary
performers let's congratulate
congratulate each one of you
individually let's
i'm looking forward to do it
congratulations rahul
congratulations sarun weldon nehal
well done data science scholars
congratulations vasu
congratulations frazil congratulations
we have ai and ml scholars great paid
job folks
congratulations vandana weldon jeffrey
congratulations rohit weldon shivendra
great job g viktor congratulations sahil
congratulations narasimha great work
david
congratulations ravindra
let's go to data analyst scholars
congratulations yogesh
congratulations slok congratulations
zinakar
weldon rose congratulations patik
weldon anusha
we have data engineering scholars
congratulations christopher
and congratulations well done
now we have business analysis folks who
have done extraordinarily well on
projects and assessments
uh congratulations nika congratulations
uh aishwarya weldon radhika
great work saleh congratulations stephen
so proud of all of you
uh digital marketing scholars very
i very congrats huge round of applause
to sri lanka
congratulations now we have the second
award which is our speed runner uh these
are our top
performers who have finished the program
the fastest
let's congratulate each one of
you
congratulations sarathi great work
jivita congratulations meredith
congratulations narasimha weldon spurti
congratulations
let's congratulate our data analyst
ticks speedrunners
congratulations dima weldon diana
congratulations aniket congratulations
kelsey
weldon anub congratulations john
congratulations christina
congratulations kumar
in our data science congratulations uh
subin
weldon shrikant weldon nehal
congratulations riho weldon ajesh
congratulations sura narayana
in data engineering speedrunners are
william congratulations congratulations
christopher
and in our business analyst program we
have
uh we have our speed runners rachel
congratulations
congratulations conrad congratulations
great job great job all of you
i'm sure all of you right now when are
in a happy spot you know in a super
happy state
uh happiness is only real when shared
this is a quote from the movie into the
wild
so i would i would encourage all of you
to share your achievements with the
world
do do share on all the social media
platforms folks
uh now let's let's close it with
some very interesting thoughts from
abhishek
our head of learner success so i would
request abhishek
to to share closing thoughts with our
learners
thank you paris am i audible yeah yeah
okay hello everyone guys this has been a
great evening so far
i think it was absolutely fascinating to
hear the stories of our learners who
have
overcome so many hurdles and challenges
um to complete this course
see learning is not easy and all of you
should be absolutely proud of what
you've accomplished
thank you for everything that you've put
into this program
and for surviving till the end of this
closing ceremony as well
yeah you know you're very much a very
diverse and accomplished
we have senior executives to engineers
we have phds we have marketeers we have
mbas
investment bankers analysts and so on
you all have essentially acquired a set
of skills and a scientific mindset
to create order from chaos and find
patterns and insights you know from
notions of data
that's that's what you've learned from
this course some of you will apply
these skills in creating products and
companies
probably medicine in science and perhaps
maybe help come up with you know drugs
to treat the coronaries
and some of you may apply this to
predict the outcomes of elections that
has become very fancy these days as an
application of data sets
but all of you will have a chance to
create impact on your own careers
with organizations and on society at
large
but as they say the fun now begins
before that i hope you're sharing your
achievements with your family friends
colleagues because you can inspire them
before i leave i want to leave you guys
with two quotes from very wise men
the first one is from jeff bezos i don't
think he needs any introduction
and this is how it goes what we need to
do is
always lean into the future when the
world changes around you
and when it changes against you what
used to be a tailwind is now a headway
you have to lean into that and figure
out what to do because complaining is
industrial
and the next one which is a very short
and crisp one is is by peter drucker
who's a great
thinker and management guru of our times
he said the best way to predict the
future is to create it
so that's what you're all in the midst
of doing not only creating your own
future
but creating the future of your
organizations and society
so with that i wish you all the very
best we would love to keep in touch
as uh paris also mentioned you know
please reach out and let us know how you
are advancing in your
we would also love to have you play an
active role in our community
there are hundreds of learners who are
coming behind you you can be mentors
to them while continuing on your forward
journey
uh so thank you again for choosing
simply learn and allowing us to be
a part of your journey have a wonderful
weekend
savor the moment and and celebrate with
your family
thank you all and good time
if there are questions any any stories
to be shared we are
still hanging around for
for a few minutes
so ankit uh we will send across the
certificates
for all the speed runners and smallers
rose the scholars were chosen based on
the performance across all projects and
assessments throughout the course
placer where nikhil has asked chuck how
will placement assistance work
uh we will reach out to unikil with the
next steps
on the alumni membership of purdue we
will purdue
will soon share the details with you it
usually takes a couple of weeks or three
weeks
post the end of the program for purdue
to induct everyone in the
alumni quote
yes it will it should be within three
weeks but
you know don't hold me to it it might
take up to a month at least
yesterday like how the scholar
certificates will be good
i think we have dr uh mate with us here
you guys uh feel free to ask any
questions that you may have
on data science on
any of the interesting topics that he
deals with
yeah most definitely and you know if you
any of you wants to reach out
to me or to my colleagues at purdue
university
uh please do so uh
we have a very rich ecosystem at purdue
for continuing education and for uh
research uh especially collaborative
research with
uh in industrial organizations or with
industry or corporations
um and here think about you know the
you know produce reputation in
industrial engineering mechanical
engineering
um in electrical engineering
um all in in the connections that we
have established between these these
fields through data science data science
is a is a core
area of interest for our university at
this point and
we are developing multiple opportunities
for conducting research
and for uh continuing
your education so never hesitate to to
reach out to us
i think one of the learners had a
question for you dr mate can we
unmute her
and then again yes sure
from delhi it's great
to be here today and i am very happy to
have this opportunity to take this
lesson through
simple learn okay i know purdue is a
good university
u.s ranking is very good yeah
my my question is we work on research
basically i work on
communication systems who are looking
for research in
sixth generation communications and
where ai
is the very important it has a lots of
role it may be the iot it may be rfid it
may be anything any communication
yeah so in that perspective i am after
this course i am
motivated to do some work on ai
particularly for the communication
engineering applications
can i have any collaborations actually i
am a phd and i am also professor in a
university uh in iot
yeah i know some people from for i mean
other departments in purdue but uh
yeah if i can have connection for the ai
uh it could be the very good to me and
also to my students
who are very most definitely
most definitely professor please do send
me an email
describe your areas of interest and i'll
try to connect you
with uh with my colleagues i
personally now the
director of the school of electrical
engineering and we had a conversation
the other day about possibilities and
potential
collaborative projects my own projects
uh the projects that i some of the
projects that i supervise and here
probably i should also say that
i'm the associate dean of research and
graduate education
and in this capacity i launch new
interdisciplinary projects that bring
together engineers with social
scientists or
archaeologists anthropologists so my own
projects
very often uh blend
advanced engineering research with
really exotic things
one of the projects that i'm about to
launch we'll use
lidar drones to discover new
archaeological structures
in greece uh we also
are interested in internet of things to
create
sensor networks to detect uh
um uh grave robbers
right like archaeological grave robbers
right
yeah yeah great and that kind of stuff
so
you know we do all kinds of interesting
things uh furthermore i'm uh
uh uh a member of a consortial of a
consortium
of uh organizations in europe that
blend technology with communication
technologies
i'm sorry communication technologies
with
um you know social scientific and
humanities research so
please okay it's great
yeah i'll i'll have your email i think
yeah
i'll get it from the website or uh we
will share it i can relate
yeah yeah no problem i'll get it i may
be linkedin or somewhere i'll get it
okay nice to talk to you okay thank you
are there another
another justification
if you allow me maybe it is open to all
all the yeah actually i am in education
industry this is my curious you know
that
new education policy of india it has
come
uh and we can give the dual degree
programs
uh in india uh that that opportunity is
going to come
and we are also time
[Music]
and we are tying up with many
universities in abroad and most most
probably the civilian will look for this
how do we think about it i mean let's
let's connect offline mr malay
on this one i can i can
and that i got it thank you thank you
for the support thank you have a great
day
okay i don't know if you are
the the representative for for simply
learning this
in this respect but maybe we should have
a conversation about
putting something in place more like a
clearing house right
uh for for projects and
interested people so that the good work
that you did to educate people continues
with
research and this can turn into another
type of training
you know absolutely and i would like to
i would very much like to join forces
with you in that respect and
i have a couple others we have a
platform that can do the matching
you know post graduation so that could
be
another way to think about it i shall i
shall get in touch uh professor
one of us
sorry uh whom prakash needs to speak
because he's wanted to ask the question
coil are you able to
yeah thank you yeah thank you everyone
and it was a good learning experience
for me so basically my background i'm a
chemical engineer
i'm working in one of the largest
refineries of the world
in india and my question is like you
know uh
i mean being a refinery every second we
generate like gigabytes of data
but you know all the engineers here uh
which we do troubleshooting and all
you know we generally just work within
excel kind of
platform or some handmade calculations
and all
so i'm just wondering like what is what
is holding back the traditional
industries like refinery
uh the steel metal and industry in you
know
uh in in in employing
this beautiful data science tool and do
a data
you know troubleshooting of that
professor madison was the question clear
i was a little technical and i'm not
sure if i
am completely qualified to answer a deep
engineering question
so can you paraphrase a little bit
for me so that i i can't i think that
yeah
yeah i think what prakash is asking is
uh traditional
industries like refineries right where
he works at oil refineries right
generate a lot of data every second
saying gigabytes of data every day
yeah yeah yeah but the the uh these
companies don't seem to deploy
ai sort of predict failures to sort of
predict
uh a lot of uh systems that might go
down right they still
they still use excel in their regular
work oh yeah how can that be changed
how can that be changed how can
traditional work yeah
well no that's an excellent question so
you know this is
uh this is a this is a question
that addresses uh the business uh
intelligence uh domain right
or that asks you know what can we do
to add true intelligence to our business
operations
and i know this is a very hot area
and i know that we have colleagues
from academia to the business world
because it's just
it just makes sense right so it's not
just failure that they predict but
business automation is is a very big
it's a very big big deal right and
business automation actually does
fall detection plus other things right
yeah no most definitely this is uh
something that
is happening that's hot and that again
colleagues that purdue can you know can
help now
again if we can you know come up with
some uh projects you know that would be
probably even better
so and i'll be more than happy to if you
know
if i get an email with a description of
a question
from perez right uh you know i'll i'll
i'll try to forward
the realm of relevant people
sure thanks for not um
okay i think rose had a question uh we
can unmute rose although she's
typed out the question it says metaverse
seems to be the future
would there be a workshop to understand
how technology is connection such as
ai and virtual realities
hello hey those
congratulations thank you appreciate it
um i live not too far from the
tech hub where um headquarters are
like facebook and google
so there's a lot of that conversation
that comes up
as far as this metaverse
i think it would be nice to have some
kind of topic or discussion about it or
just to kind of bring all of us together
i don't come from
sure i think uh we will take that
feedback and we'll
see if any webinar can be arranged for
this
why our experts either refer to you or
you know pretty much those partners
that would see
is there anyone else
cool i think if there are no further
questions
uh for professor then i think we can
call it a night or evening or
day um
great so thank you everyone for for
joining this event thanks paris for
hosting this uh thanks a lot professor
matai for
for uh coming here and encouraging our
learners
um it was great to have you here i
i wish you all of all our learners i
wish you all
very best for your endeavors going
forward
okay practice time yesterday right this
is this is now where you
sort of put good things to practice in
the real world
but anyways i uh wish you guys all the
very best and
and have a great future ahead we would
love to hear from you so
keep writing to us uh and we can always
put in touch with
our experts at purdue professor
himself and others as well so
at that i think we can take your leave
this is a great
ceremony a great convocation ceremony
which has been
placed by all of you thanks a lot for
attending good night
and good day
thank you everyone
you